[Musique]
bon appétit
pour
[Musique]
je crois à la
au lightning
[Musique]
la nuit ce patron qui alla véhicules qui
passent là des véhicules qui passent il
ya de bruit il ya des gens aussi qui
parle il ya des gens aussi qui dort pas
il ya des débris qu'il ya c'est pas
super c'est pas facile qu'avec ce n'est
pas du tout facile
est-ce que c'est dangereux trop trop
dangereux
quand tu sors la nuit à des brigands il
ya des brodeurs tu pètes aménagé qui
peut être pour aider tous étude
[Musique]
américaine vient le ramener jusqu'à 70
personnes et alès l'autre pourquoi elle
en prend pas plus je ne viens pas
d'hébergement et pas des places comme
cela tu apprends que va envoyer des
courriers soit on appelle est là tant
qu'à moi c'est moi c'est moi et que tant
qu'il a des griefs où il ya plein plan
du logement ici il ya beaucoup de
maisons ici france il ya beaucoup de
maisons il ya des mesures il ya des
squats il ya des mesures même qui sont
abandonnés marseille ici que je vis en
tant que même en italie et même malgré
son raciste quand même les zones d'eau
par dana au mali sont racistes quand
même les angles droits de l'homme